so I'm not sure how my family and I are
going to recover from this
the mud sticks
and I feel it may take some time but the
family we remain strong
and we will be strong
and we determined to move forward
positively with our lives and we're not
and we won't be leaving but we will be
still remaining empowerment foreign
yeah
it's it's it's it's a it's concerning
because it's still out there there is
people out there in social media the
family is doing the campaign of that
it's it's still the truth and there's
still people on social media and this
goes to the far right element of people
are still portraying this this actually
exists and this happened and it hasn't
it doesn't
it's what we've been through it's it's
difficult it's been hard it's very
impacted it's impacted us all in
different words yeah that's snower and
we've got to think about moving forward
she'd made some mistakes and she's sorry
she was young and confused and not
saying guilty but I know I've done some
wrong what do you say to that so there
you can see you you did there's been
plenty of time to stop and realize what
I've done wrong I hold my hands up you
know like I said I'm No Angel and in the
past I was talking about with you and
then and hold you hold your hands up
that's and that's the best thing to do
and the train left the station far too
before they could actually tell the food
thank you
yes that is yes there is and we have
mentioned this at the MP with Simon fell
and there is things that we are as
working on ourselves as a campaign we
are taking on the campaign to change the
social media laws in the UK we are
looking at that as a family and we are
setting up we've set up a foundation we
are working on moving forward because of
this I've had actual victims come out to
be real victims or abuse real victims of
wrongly arrest wrongly accused to
because of the way I it's a huge problem
it is a problem it's a true problem and
I'm not taking the facts away from real
victims the real victims do exist there
is issues of grooming their sexual
problem but how are we as a government
as a country how the balances it's not
right it's not right and the support our
boys our kids kids future the future
yeah it's a massive worry many many
she's been able to say this and falsify
all this happy and we've gone through
this for three and a half years our life
has been put through the mill and
luckily we are strong and we've got
through it but yeah and that's one thing
we'd like to say to thank you because
this one thing has taught us as a family
we are strong we are unbreakable and
we're the strong family and that's all
we um
priceless priceless yeah you've got to
take a positive from what's happened
rather than a negative eight and a half
years enough
that's the judge's decision I was just
happy with the guilty verdict
and I'm not gonna waste my time I'm not
going to be better I'm not going to be
thinking
there's a bigger picture to this and
which in time will be revealed I'm sure
we'll see who and what was behind us and
I'm sure you know
no it doesn't but would we believe the
truth if she told us
even if she comes out with the truth
who's actually willing to believe
I think she does yes she does she does
need help before she's released I think
there should be a lot of courses that
need to be attended yeah yeah
I thought I'm a father
she's a young girl and you've got to see
where did you read the way I see this is
where the teachings come from you can
learn academically at the school you can
learn about a religion in a church or a
mosque but your values your traditions
they come from they come from your
parents they come from your the
classroom your life
yeah I I can't thank them enough and
divide the it's a howling time never had
a hiring experience of 10 weeks of Life
obviously sustained their life you know
this is every day is you know it's it's
and you start here listening to this one
lie after another or one case of none
other and I just I'm just I'm so
thankful that they did the right thing
and the officers you know at the
beginning I said it was a much of an
inconvenience of what they did to us
when the police took all our devices
took our phones that the the businesses
and it was it was at that time it was a
lot of frustration it was anger towards
the police the deal what the hell
they're doing but I am glad that they're
dead because that gave us every evidence
every shed of Doubt was given and I I
give them all my devices all my kids
devices everything every electronic
device you can think of in the house and
business related was taken so there was
no doubt in any way of the investigation
and I'm so thankful to Dougie Marsh
Andrew Hill Gary Hugh and Captain John
Robinson what a legend of a prophecy was
and report a call I can't thank the
police enough for doing what they did
yes positively with a massively we are
this is the closure this is it we're
moving on
thank you very much everyone thank you
thank you